interviewed Chris Paul they'd be like
two years ago
and you're talking about LeBron and he
says Taylor LeBron is the most frugal
person I know he says when we walk into
a place the first thing LeBron says is
what's the Wi-Fi password I don't want
to use my data oh yeah yeah oh yeah I've
seen that a million times in Toronto
that drive from the airport and going
through customs to then getting to our
hotel yeah there's no there's no data
used at all like he's waiting for the
Wi-Fi all the time and so that then that
drive from the hotel to then the arena
uh Air Canada also waits for to get to
the Wi-Fi like that's so funny you know
like what's a finance grade saying uh a
small leak can sink a great ship but
like that's like that's not
that's not
you know I can appreciate it yeah